[موسيقى]
طب توم و طابت اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى
بانوراما وهذه عنوانها الرئيس
2002 2020
في القرن الحالي وهل القادم افضل ام اشد
سوهاج
[موسيقى]
يشكى لعام 2022 على الرحيل عام وانتم تميز
بالاحداث العالميه غير المسبوقه احداثا لا
شك ان تاثيرها سيستمر الى العام المقبل
وربما الاعوام المقبله شهد العالم هذا
العام العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا التي قد تكون الحدث الاهم
للتداعيات الكبيره التي اسفرت عنها الحرب
المستمره في تصعيد لا يعرف متى وكيف تتوقف
او تنتهي العالم واجهه في العام المنصرم
عزمات سياسيه كبيره
اعتقد الكثيرون لانها ذكر كالحرب البارده
تحالفات الدوليه الصراعات على الموارد
التوتر من الصين شرقا والكوريتين واليابان
وروسيا والغرب الى الصين وامريكا العام
المنتهي شهد بدايه
شديده السخونه للمنافسه على السباق
الرئاسيه الانتخابيه الامريكيه كما شهد
جدلا على بيض وترامب المرشحين لخوض هذا
السباق والجدل المستمر ومتصاعد هذا العام
العالم واجه ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره من تضخم
ارتفاعا في الاسعار اسعار الوقود والغاز
دفعت الى البحث عن مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
عدا عن انهيارات في البورصه وتبخر الثقه
في العملات المشفره
الى المنطقه وقبل ان يدخل عام 2022 في
ربعه الاخير ياتي يوم السادس عشر من
سبتمبر ليكون انطلاقا
للاحتجاجات على مقتله مساء ميمي حيث غضب
شارع الايراني دون ان يهدا منذ ذلك
التاريخ وعلى
على كل حال هذا العام لم يكن في احسنه على
الاطلاق كوارث طبيعيه من فيضانات وزلازل
في باكستان وافغانستان وحرائق غابات الى
عاصفه القرن في هذا العام وصل عدد البشر
الى 8 مليارات والرقم اخذ في الارتفاع اما
الحصاد الايجابي الذي خلفه عام 2022 قد
يكون انتهاء جائعات كورونا ورفع القيود
والاجراءات الاحترازيه وان ما زالت الصين
بؤره الوباء تسجل اصابات لهذه اللحظه
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
ايه
فادي
[موسيقى]
احب
[تصفيق]
الينا من القاهره دكتوره عبد المنعم سعيد
عضو مجلس الشيوخ ومن بروكسل عبر سكايب
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه جنيف ومحاضر في معهد
العلوم السياسيه في باريس ومن الكويت عبر
سكايب الدكتور سعد بن طفله وزيره الاعلام
الكويتي سابقا والكاتب الصحفي واهل استاذ
الجامعي شكرا جزيلا لكم اهلا بكم
نستطيع ان نقول كل عام وانتم بخير مسبقا
ولكن همم سؤال همم الدكتور عبد المنعم هل
يعتبر هذا العام دكتور هو الاسوا اسوا
الاعوام في هذا القرن هل نستطيع ان نقول
ذلك
بالطبع يعني من الصعب مقارنه الايام
الصعبه والحزينه في تاريخ البشريه لكن انا
اعتقد ان عام 2020 كان اكثر سوءا عندما
بدا انتشار وباء كرونه في العالم كله لانه
اولا تقريبا لم يترك دوله دون ان يمسهاها
ثانيا كان معملا رئيسا في
الدار الكبير باقتصاديات العالميه ابدى
بعد ذلك الى موجات من البطاله لا تزال
موجوده معنا حتى الان وهي بطاله طبيعيه
لان الباحثين عن عن العمل باتوا يريدون
العمل من منازلهم وهي عاده اكتسبوها بسبب
ال- ال- الكرونه همم لكن ايضا كانت شهاده
على نوع من التعاون العالمي حول انتاج
اللقاحات والعلاجات وتنظيم عمليه انتقال
البشر همم لكن انا اعتقد ان ما زال عام
2020 انه ما جرى فيه كان اقصر قسوه همم
لكن المساله هي انها عام 2020 بات له لقاح
وعلاج لكن الان الازمه الاوكرانيه لا يعرف
احد الى اين سوف تسير وهناك كثير من
الشوائب انها سوف تكون معنا لفتره طويله
مقبله الدكتور حسني هل توافق الدكتور عبد
المنعم على كل ذلك ان همم ربما هذا العام
كان اخذت من همم ما سياتي وربما ما سبق
يعني نادر المشاهدت ااا يعني سنه كامله
احداث يمكننا القول بان احداث مفصليه ليس
فقط في المنطقه العربيه وانما كذلك حتى في
في العالم يعني سواء في العلاقات
الاوروبيه وعلاقات ما بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده وعلاقات امريكا مع اسيا
وحتى داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما
اريد ان اقول انه هذه السنه احدثت فعلا
يعني هزات على كل الاسعده على الصعيد
المناخي وهذا مهم جدا على كذلك على الصعيد
السياسي يعني هناك تغيير خريطه اوروبيه
كانت اوروبا تقول ان ان هناك قدسيه للحدود
منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه الان
نرى بان دوله مهمه في روسيا يعني تشك يعني
الحدود وتريد حدود جديده وبالتالي النقطه
اللي همم المصري نقطه الثالثه وهي قضيه لا
يحدث يحدث في ايران يعني اتظاهرات
الداخليه استطعت ان تؤثر على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اكثر ما استطعت ان توفر
اوروبا وهي قضيه التريث او حتى ربما
الابتعاد نهائيا على اتفاق النووي سنه
2022 مفصليه ومهمه وخطره جدا لان
التداعيتها ستكون لن تكون مختصره على سنه
واحده وانما ستكون يعني
ستستمر معنا لسنوات جديده فعلا غيرت خريطه
العالم واعطت كذلك ربما تحالفات
وتفاهمات اقليبيه والدوليه لم يشهدها
العالم منذ نهايه الحرب الدكتور سعد يعني
هذا العالم هو سيء ام هو الاسود بين
التفاؤل والتشائم اين تكون
هيك استاذ عادل وظيفيكم مشاهديك الكرام
واقول للجميع كل عام وانتم بخير
الحقيقه على عكس الزميلين الفاضلين سابدا
بدوائر اصغر ربما فيها نفحات تفاؤل اقصد
بالدوائر الخليجيه يمكن كويتيا كان لدينا
اول انتخابات تعقد باعتراف حكومي ضمني
بانها اول انتخابات بلا تدخل حكومي في
الانتخابات وهذا شيء جيد حدث همم شهدت
المنطقه الخليج همم حدثين هامين همم الاكس
بول لاول مره يعقد في هذه المنطقه في دوله
عربيه وايضا كاس العالم لاول مره يعقد في
دوله عربيه او دوله خليجيه او دوله من دول
العالم الثالث بين قوسين الى جائزه
التسميه وانتهت بمفخره الحقيقه سواء الاكس
بو او كاس العالم هذان حدث حدثان همم
تويجا بحدث ربما اكبر على صعيد التحولات
الجيو سياسيه تجاه هذه المنطقه
بالقمم الصينيه العربيه التي حدثت همم
خلال همم خلال لسابع الماضي كل هذه
التحولات تتوج ايضا لنفح التفاؤل اخرى وهي
بوقف الحرب وليس وقف الاقتتال في اليمن
وهذا الحقيقه هو البدايه الذي نتمنى ان
يكون هدنه مطلقه مهم جدا ما اشار له
الدكتور حسني في ما يتعلق بما يحدث في
ايران انا طبعا ليس من المتفائلين بما
سيجري للانسان الايراني على المدى القصير
واعتقد بانه لم يظهر بشاعته بعد همم ولكن
في المقابله اعتقد بان هناك تخلي من
العالم الذي يدعيه حقوق الانسان عن ما
يجري الانسان الايراني اليوم هذا انا
اعتقد ربما جانب متشائم همم للاسف الشديد
لكن هذا هو واقع الحاله اعتقد بان المنطقه
اليوم همم اقتطبت وتستقطب بقياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
اهتماما دوليا بسبب ما يجري في هذه
المنطقه من تفكير منهجي مختلف تقود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تجاه ضروره
الاقتصاد والتركيز عليه وان القوه
الحقيقيه لهذا العالم هو في القوه
الاقتصاديه وهذا ما اثبتته بقدرتها على
تنوع اتجاهاتها من الغرب مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واوروبا ومن الشرق
والشمال مع روسيا كمال ومع تفصيل شرقا ومع
دول شرق اسيا هذه كلها اعتقد مؤشرات على
تطورات جنسيه لهذه المنطقه فيها نفحات
تفاؤل وان كان هذا التفاعل المشروب بالحذر
لان هذه منطقه الشرق الاوسط ما تعرف شنو
ممكن يحصل بكره طيب منطقه الشرق الاوسط
الدكتور سعد يعني ليست بعيده عما يحدث من
الشان الاقليمي وكذلك ايضا الدوري حتى في
همم اذا ما تحدثنا عن الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هل الحرب ذاتها هي سيئه
امتداعياتها الاسوا ستكون
ليس هناك حرب ليست سيئه يعني يعني اقدر
كلمه في قاموس اي لغه يقول لك هذا الكلام
هي الحرب كلمه الحرب لان في الحرب انت
انسان عادي تقتل انسان عادي ما تعرف اسمه
ولا عمرك شفته ولا قابلته ولا تدري وهو
طيب وزينه وتعلم عند عيال متزوج سعيد تعيس
مالك اي علاقه تقتل انسان مالك علاقه فيه
ولا عمرك شفته ومن هنا هي حقيقه يعني اسفل
درجات السلوك الانساني ما يسمى بالحرب
طبعا انظر اليوم الى هذه الحرب التي اتفق
مع الدكتور عبد المنعم بان الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه يراد لها ان تكون
مستنقعا لروسيا لاهداف بعيده استراتيجيه
بعيده المدى استراتيجيه للغرب بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه الحرب
اعاده الاهتمام الى الناتو من جديد بعد ان
كان قد ضعوا ضعف وتلاشى الى حد ما اثناء
اداره الرئيس دون ترامب اتت هذه الحرب
لتحيه مره اخرى بقياده همم جو بايدن
ومحاوله الصف الدول الناعته وانضمام
السويد فيلندا اعضاء جدد لهذا الناتج انا
اعتقد بان هذه الحرب ستور واتمنى يكون
هناك مبادرات سلام ربما تقودها دوله مثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مثل دوله مثل
الهند ودول اخرى ربما تستطيع ان توقف هذا
الدمار الذي قد قرر له الغرب ان يكون حتى
اخر انسان اوكراني وانا يعني وجهه نظر
متواضعه جدا ان هذا العالم وهذا الانسان
الاوكراني هو ضحيه حرب
ويعني مهرج من جانب اخر وهذه هي الماسات
طيب الدكتور عبد المنعم همم هل تشارك
الدكتور سعد هذا التفاؤل ام ان بالفعل هو
التهديد بالحرب وما وقع في الحرب
الاوكرانيا الروسيه همم ربما على الاقل
كما يقال راس جبل الجليد والقادم تداعيات
هذه الحرب هو الاسود
يعني
الزميل العزيز ذكر نظره متفائله بالنسبه
لمنطقه الخليج واقفل نقطه هامه وهو ارتفاع
اسعار النفط التي يعني استفادت من الدول
الخليج بشكل جيد
وزادت من دورها الدولي وايضا من قدرتها
على
القيام بمبادرات عديده ناموا لان تسير في
الاتجاه الذي قال به لكن معظم بقيه
البشريه يعني كانت هذه الحرب وبالا عليها
ارتفاع
التضخم والركود العالمي بشكل عام ازمه
الطاقه بالنسبه للدول التي لا تولد طاقه
بتروليه او غازيه همم
الازمه في العموم الخاصه بسلائل همم يعني
وسائل ال- همم
التوريد التي تاتي من بين دول العالم
وبعضها البعض وذلك جعل الازمتين مركبتين
بمعنى ان الازمه الاوكرانيه اصبح مضافا
لها ازمه الكرونه التي لا استسلم انا انها
قد انتهت بالشكل الذي بدا به البرنامج
اننا في عام جديد وانها
من العام القادم ربما يكون اسود ما زالت
فيها كورونا
هذا صحيح همم لانه اما نتحدث عن اكثر من
250 مليون صيني مصاب الان وان معدلات من
الصعب يعني احنا بدانا بضعه الاف في عام
2020 همم ثم انتشرت الى بقيه العالم همم
الان في نوع من الاسكان العالميه لهذا ال-
الوباء حتى الان لم تعلن حالات الطوارئ
بالشكل الذي يجب ان يحدث فنحن لدينا الانف
ونحن نواجه عام 20 23
ازمه مركبه ما بين الكرونه وما بين الحرب
الاوكرانيه اللي هي منذره بتوسع جديد نظرا
لمعاهده الدفاع المشترك التي بين روسيا
وبيل روسيا التي توجد هي من الناحيه الجيو
السياسيه
في شمال اوكرانيا فاحتمال توسيع نطاق
الحرب ربما سوف يبادله توسيع نطاق همم
اربع ايضا من الناحيه الغربيه باشكال
متعدده قد تكون بحريه قد تكون سبرانيه قد
تكون همم لا علاقه
بالتعامل مع جبهات متعدده وليس جبهه همم
واحده
فنحن اذا اعام جديد مركب لازمات مختلفه
همم كلها بتجعل دول العالم والاغلبيه
الساحقه من الثمانيه مليار اا انسان على
وجه الكوكب
يتعرضه لكثير من العمل ومع ذلك هناك
بشارات جديده في العالم همم في الجانب
التكنولوجي في الحقيقه يعني همم التواصل
الى نتائج هامه في موضوع الاندماج النووي
يبشر بان همم ان العالم من الممكن ان
يواجه عن مواطن من الطاقه الجديده والارخص
والاكثر يعني همم نظافه في ال- ال- العالم
هناك اشكال تكنولوجيه جديده لها علاقه
بالمدن والعمران والى اخره العالم في اا
يعني اشكال له تتقدم لكن يوجد الامور التي
لها تصرفات انسانيه او منفرده بها بشر
واحد مثل السيد بوتين من الممكن ان تاخذ
العالم الى اتجاهات صعبه طيب يعني الدكتور
همم حسني همم
اليوم همم الحديث عن الحرب على الاوكرانيه
همم لابد ان نقول بان هناك تهديد بحروب
اخرى في المنطقه الكوريتين ما يحدث في شرق
همم اسيا وبالتالي او في همم يعني ايضا في
مناطق اخرى ساخنه لكن من عكس في هذه الحرب
على العالم هو الاسواق من وقوع هذه الحرب
هل توافق ذلك
انا اتفق معك يعني تداعيات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هي التي يمكن ان تشكل خطر
وبدات فعلا يعني
ترتسم ملامح هذا التهديد خذ مثلا قضيه
الاقليات الان هناك مشكله كبيره ما بين
الصور ما بين صربيا وبين العقليه الصربيه
الموجوده في كتب قضيه الحدود هي قنبله
موقوتا داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي
يعني منذ منذ 2004
جزيره القرم ولم تستطع ربه في النهايه
البث في قضيه الاقليات وفي قضيه الحدود
ولدينا هذه المشكله موجوده في العديد من
الدول الاوروبيه لن نذهب الى مثلا
اوكرانيا
التي يمكن كذلك ان تستخدم الولايات
المتحده في همم في نزاعلها مع مع الصين
لكن التداعيات مثلا لو اخذت اوروبا اوروبا
هي كانت رمز في النهائي للرفاع الاقتصادي
لان اوروبا سلمت امنها لان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحت
راسي واستطاعت اوروبا في النهايه الذهاب
بعيد القضيه الانعاش الاقتص واصبحت يعني
قاره فعلا اقتصاديا
تسجل مستوى مهم جدا الان مستويات التسلح
داخل التي اتحاد الاوروبي بالاضافه كذلك
الى التوسع الحلف الاطلسي وصلنا الى عسكرت
فعلا الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي هناك خوف
كبير على ان نمو الاقتصاد الذي شهاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيتدهور وبالتالي سيؤدي كذلك الى تدهور
العديد من الدول المرتبطه الاتحاد
الاوروبي نقطه نقطه ثانيه لو سمحت
لي دول متوسط متوسطه ان تتحرر نوع من
التبعيه راينا الدوره الرياضي مثلا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن في نفس
الوقت العديد من الاصوات داخل الولايات
المتحده وحتى هنا في بروكسل تقول لابد من
لابد من هذه الدول ومنها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الجزائر مثلا قطر الدول
المصدره للطاقه ان تكون او لنقل ان همم
قريبه من الولايات المتح الغرب ولذلك هناك
خوف كبير على او التسعير اسعار النفط
والغاز المصدره من هذه الدول فنرى فعلا
انه ال-
ال- حتى للدول الاخرى التي تقول انها هي
في النهايه لا تريد للحجاز لا لا معسكر
الشرق ولا للغرب لن لن يكون سهلا بالنسبه
لها ان تكون في منئه عن التداعيات الخطيره
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه لهذا
التجربه بين الغربروسيا طيب يعني اليوم
مثل ما تفضل دكتور حسن يعني اسعار النفط
هل همم الدكتور همم سعد همم
نذهب الى تسعير النفط كما ذهبته اوروبا
الى تسعيره الغاز همم من روسيا هل من
الممكن ان يتغير ذلك النظام ويؤثر على
الدول الخليجيه مستقبلا وحتى الدول
العربيه المصدره للنفد
يعني لازم نتذكر بانها النفط هو سلعه
والسلعه دائما تخضع للعرض والطلب والعرض
والطلب هنا العرض ليس فقط اوروبا وليس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمناسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تستورد
كثيرا من نفط الخليج ومنطقه الخليج يعني
ومعظم يعني ما يتم تصدير منطقه الخليج
يذهب اما الى اوروبا او الى الدرجه الاولى
شرق اسيا وبالتالي الحديث برايي مع كل
الاحترام اختلف بانه ممكن ان يطرح مثل هذا
السيناري هيك عن انه طرح في اوروبا موضوع
تسعير النقط الروسي الروس رفضوا هذه
تسعيره وبالتالي هم ما عندهم بدائل ماذا
يمكن يعني يعلمون ربما الدكتور حسني في
بروكسل يشاهد الان ااه التقشف في موضوع
الطاقه ويشهد كيف انه هناك يعني نوع من
همم شد الحزام من اجل تقليل من الطاقه
والاضاءه وغيرها رغم ان هذه فتره اعياد
والفتره اضاء لكن هناك كثير من السياسات
التقشفيه التي تتبعها اوروبا انا اعتقد
بان ايضا برايي متواضع ستعلوا الاصوات
الاوروبيه التي ستقول نحن الذين نكتتوي
بنار اتباع او ااا السير وراء السياسه
الامريكيه في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيا
الروسيه اعتقد ان هذه الاصوات يعني
ستتصاعد وربما الزملاء او الزميل حسني
يشهد بعض هذه الاعتراضات وهناك من يرى
ضروره ان يكون هناك جلوس على المفاوضات من
اجل انهاء هذه الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن الجلد
الامريكيه مختلفه تماما تعتقد بان همم
يجب ان تكون
مثل ما كانت افغانستان للاتحاد السوفيتي
لهذا الشيء يعني وهذا يترتب عليه تغيرات
كبيره تغيرات في موضوع الطاقه في اسعار
الطاقه لا اعتقد بانه ممكن بالاخير انت
كمشتري وما عندك الا جهه واحده تشتري منها
ما تقدر يعني خاصه ان هذه سلعه حيويه ما
تقول ان والله انا ممكن انا اكتفي من
التشوكليت واكل تمر مثلا يعني لكن هذه
بالنسبه للطاقه وبالنسبه للغاز والنفط لا
تستطيع ان تقوم بذلك مهما حاولت المفاعلات
النوويه حاليا وبعض التكنولوجيا همم
البديله والطاقه البديله ان تعوض على
النفط والغاز الا انه لا يزال لا تزعل هذه
النسبه قليله وهو مكلفه مقارنه باسعار
النفط والغاز الذي هو في السوق العالميه
اليوم الدكتور حسنين يعني بالقرب من
بروكسل هل تتوقع ان ذلك قد يحدث قريبا من
الدول الاوروبيه خاصه انه هذه الاصوات او
هذه الرؤيه بالفعل موجوده في اوروبا لا
يريدون الارتباط بحرب اوكرانيا وبالتالي
هم لا يدفعون الثمن بازمه الطاقه
يعني هي بدات بقوه بمنذو انتصار اليمين
المتطرف وانا عديد من الاحزاب الشعبويه
التي اصبحت بها تمثيل كبير في البرلمانات
ومنها من وصل حتى الى السلطه ولا مثلا في
ايطاليا وننتظر الانتخابات المقبله ستكون
في اسبانيا وفي العديد كذلك من دول اوروبا
الشماليه متطرف قوي في فرنسا والرئيس
ماكرون يعني يعمل 1000 حساب لحزب الحزب
السيده مريم
هذا الخطاب الجديد الخطاب هويتي خطاب مبني
كذلك على اولويه اوروبا اولويه اوروبا قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك حتى حديث
حول فكر ارتباط مع الحلف الاطلسي رغم انه
هناك يعني نوع من العالمين عندما يتعلق
الامر بقضيه العلاقه العسكريه مع الحلف
الاطلسي فعلا هناك اصوات يعني في العديد
من الاحزاب الاساسيه التي تقول بانه لابد
على الاقل من من اختبار مقارنه جديده
مقاربه دبلوماسيه لانها هذه القرض اصبحت
مكلفه بالنسبه للمواطنه الاوروبي ورغم
يعني رغم البرامج التي تحفيزيه الكبيره
اللي انا اعتقد اذا طالت الحرب فان ستكون
تكاليفها يعني فاتوره اجتماعيا والفاتوره
السياسيه قويه جدا هناك حتى تشكيك في همم
في ماده ماده قوه الاتحاد الاوروبي وكيف
اصبح الان يعني بالنسبه لبعض سياساته همم
يعني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه افريقيا
الدكتور عبد المنعم ايضا انك همم كما هي
بعض الدول او العديد من دول العالم
بنار ارتفاع
نسب التضخم وبالتالي انعكست على همم
المواطن وحتى على الدول همم بعضها بدا
باتخاذ همم اجراءات
شديده القسوه
دكتور عبد المنعم
كنت انتظر السؤال بعد ذلك يعني هذا هذا
الامر ما يتحدث عنه الدكتور سعد والدكتور
حسني من انه هذه الحرب وتداعياتها اثرت
على المنطقه وبالتالي حتى في ارتفاع اسعار
التضخم في الدول الافريقيه ايضا هي التي
تعاني وبالتالي غيرت حتى من اعطيها
السياسي مع بعض القضايا وحتى في الداخل
الافريقي تغيرت
افريقيا تاثرت بجميع الازمات لا ننسى انه
كان هناك عقود كامله داخل افريقيا التي
جرت فيها حروب اهليه مروعه وبعدها جاءت
يعني وجاءت افريقيا ايضا الكورونا تواجه
بقوه ايضا موضوع الاحتباس الحراري
وتاثيراته على القاره
افريقيا بالفعل تعاني من هذه الازمه
الاخيره الاوكرانيه الموجوده وللاسف
الشديد انها سوف تكون ممتده ليس فقط في
اسعار الطاقه ولكن ايضا في اسعار الغذاء
والواردات بشكل عام ههه حتى الان لا يوجد
سياسات افريقيه نستطيع ان نقول انها
لمواجهه هذا الموقف هناك افكار هناك
شعارات لكن سياسات لا تزال همم بعيده همم
بعضها يحاول ان يتحاول يعني يتحول الى نوع
من التعاون الاقليمي لكن اي انتاج ايجابي
له سوف ياخذ فتره طويله لذلك نجد ان مواقف
الدول الافريقيه من الحرب اخذت الموقف
العام في كثير من دول العالم النامي من
انها يعني لاتو اي ضروسيا ولا تؤيد
اوكرانيا وانما تمتنع عن التصويت واذا
صوتت فانها تصوت ضد الغزو كذلك تصوت ضد
العقوبات الاقتصاديه الموجهه ااه الى الى
روسيا همم فهنا في افريقيا ربما تكون همم
لا اقول انها الضحيه الاولى ولكنها ضحيه
اساسيه لانها هل هذا يجعلنا امام نظام
عالم جديد دكتور عبد المنعم يعني كل هذه
التغيرات البعض يريد فك الارتباط بامريكا
باوروبا تريد حتى الارتباط همم الطاقه مع
روسيا وايجاد بديل هل ذلك سيكل نظاما
عالميا جديدا انتهى ما كنا همم يعني نراه
ونشهده خلال العوامل السابقه
يعني النظام الاعلام الجديد يحدث كل يوم
نتيجه المتغيرات الجاريه في العالم سواء
تغيرات تكنولوجيه او تغيرات تاريخيه كما
وجدنا في الجائحه ونجد الان في في الحرب
لكن انا ادعوا الى عدم التعجل يعني لانه
الاعلام عاده وانا ايضا في المجال الاعمال
في المجال الاعلامي
نتعجل فكره التغيرات الدوليه الكبيره
الحقائق اللي هي ممتده معنا بلا جدال من
الازمه السابقه للكرونه وهو ان الولايات
المتحده المستمره كقوه عظمى في العالم
ويقابلها ان هناك صعودا قويا في من الصين
فالدينا نوع من القطبيه الثنائيه الجديده
لكنها هذه المره بين الصين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهذه لا توابعها في
منطقه شرق اسيا سواء بالنسبه لكوريا
الشماليه او موضوع تايوان هذا الموضوع
يمكن ان ناتي له لكن انا اريد ان اقول ان
كبير الان وهو موقع روسيا بعد هذه الازمه
يعني لو احنا تابعنا وللاسف لا اجد متابعه
يعني كرونولوجيه بمعنى انها تشوف تتابع
المواقف المختلفه الروسيه منذ الازمه
الاوكرانيه ثم انتقالها الى الحرب
الاوكرانيه الحديث كما قال احد الزملاء
انه
الغرب يريد استدراك روسيا لكي تكون
اوكرانيا همم يعني هي افغانستان روسيا
الغرب جلس لمده اكثر من شهر او خمسه
اسابيع يطرح الخطه الروسيه للهجوم على
اوكرانيا ولم يكن هناك يعني تحذير اكثر من
ذلك من توابع مثل هذه الخطوه لانه ما نشر
في ذلك الوقت خلال الاسابيع الاولى من
فبراير والاخيره من من يناير كانت عن
الخطه ومحاور الهجوم والاهداف التكتيكيه
الاولى والاخيره وك السيد بوتين يضع سقف
مطالبه في تغيير النظام الحاكم الموجود في
اوكرانيا وفي ان اوكرانيا يتم نزع سلاحها
الى اخره فلدينا مواقف كثيره متغيره الان
نسمع من روسيا انها تريد التفاوض وان تبقي
على المحافظات الاربعه التي
في الولايات المتحده قبل بدايه الحرب كانت
همم يعني الانباء التي ترد منها ان لا حرب
ستاتي في القريب العاجل وهذا همم هذا ما
كان واضحا حتى قبيلا اندلاع الحرب طيب
اذهب الى الدكتور سعد بن طفله دكتور سعد
النظام العالمي هل
بالتالي سيتغير عمليه القطبيه همم كما قال
الدكتور عبد المنعم ستتحول الى امريكا
والصين همم انه هناك ربما همم بشكل جديد
كيف ملامح هذا النظام العالمي اذا ما
اردنا ان نستطلع الارى ولا نستعجل في همم
ربما
يعني في البدايه بس التقط ما تفضلت به
يعني من ان فكر ارتباط هذا العالم مترابط
لا يمكن ان يفك الارتباط يعني حتى ونحن
نتحدث الان وقد سرق رئيس اوكرانيا بان
زينسكي
بان الامريكان والروسي يلتقون ويتحاورون
حول اوكرانيا دون علمه يعني اريد ان اقول
بان ما تستطيع في عالم اليوم لا يستطيع
طرف ان يفك نفسه عن طرف اخر العالم متشابك
اليوم والمصالح ومتشابكه وهذه حقيقه هذا
العالم الجديد الذي يتشكل يتشكل بفعل هذه
الثوره التكنولوجيه والرقميه والتي نعيشها
اليوم لا حبي بان
بقي النظام كما هو عليه على الاقل لنقل
الماليه فان موضوع مثلا الايبان سوف يجعل
يعني يرهن مصائر واموال ومؤسسات ماليه
كبيره في العالم همم بيد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك من يفكر اليوم بالخروج من
هذا اول انطلاق من هذه الرقه من هذا لان
العتاب من هذا القيم وهو قيد الايبان الذي
يتحكم به الامريكان ومن هنا جاءت فكره دول
البريكس اللي هي روسيا والهند والصين
وجنوب افريقيا والبرازيل ودول الان يعني
تسعى الى ان تكون على الاقل العظام مراقبه
مثل مصر مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهل
مجرب حتى الامارات العربيه المتحده يعني
هناك محاولات لدى اطراف عديده في هذا
العالم لان لا تضع البيت في سله واحده فقط
وبالتالي تنوع من اقتصاداتها لانك لا
تستطيع ان تنفك من الصين وتقول انا والله
باتبع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حصرا
ولكنك لا تستطيع في نفس الوقت ان تقول
بانني استطيع ان اعيش بدون روايات المتحده
الامريكيه والعلاقات معها ولاحظ عندنا في
المنطقه العربيه ربما
امثله كثيره يعني
جابه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مجابهه مباشره يعني انتهى الى دمار يعني
سواء في العراق او في ليبيا اولائك الذين
في ايران اليوم بسبب الحصار الذي يتعرضون
له من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
مدى الاربعين سنه الماضيه انظري الى حال
الانسان الايراني اليوم انا لا اقول بان
سياسات الامريكيه واا يعني سياسات صحيح
مدمره في بعض الاحيان ولكن في نفس الوقت
لاحظ لانك تتحدث عن قطب جديد
وهو الصين على عكس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهو الاقتصاد والتكنولوجيا
والعسكره طيب وهذه الحقيقه يعني الدكتور
حسن الدكتور سعد لا بد ان استوقف يعني قبل
قليل تحدث عن ايران وتحدثت انك متخوف على
الانسان الايراني مما سيواجههم مستقبلنا
هل سيكون العام القادم هو اسوا على رنين
رغم ان هذه الاحتجاجات قد تكون هي
المختلفه في هذا العام عن همم الثوره
الخضراء وغيرها
بتوع الموجه لي نعم دكتور ايه
يمكن ادعي باني متابع يعني الاحداث في
ايران وغير متفائل على المدى القصير بان
يمكن ان يكون هناك يعني تغيرات يعني ممكن
ان تخفف الوضعه الوحشيه ضد الانسان
الايراني وخصوصا ان الغرب غير مهتم بهذه
المساله انا اعرف هذا الشيء ايضا مثل ما
تفضل دكتور عبد المنعم اعرف تابع الاعلام
وتابع الاعلام الغربي متى ما كان في
الهدلان نيوز في الخبر الاول عن هذه
القضيه تصبح هي الاشياء الشغل الشاعر لان
التقديم تركيز كما يقولون يعني فرنتيز
هايلايتنج حين تقدم شيء في الاخبار انت
تؤكد على اهميه بالنسبه لك ياتي خبر ربما
ثانويه ياتي تقرير هنا ياتي تقرير هناك
على استحياء لكن للاسف الشديد اعتقد بان
العالم الغربي تحديدا العالم بشكل عام
لسياسات مختلفه يعني بسبب علاقات مختلفه
مع ايران همم تخلى او يتخلى عن الانسان
الاي يعني هذا من ناحيه ناحيه اخرى انا
اعرف بان لدى النظام لا يزال قوه عاتيه
تستطيع ان توجه نحو الانسان ولم يكشف عن
وحشيه بعد واعتقد بان للاسف الشديد سيكون
هناك مزيد من الخسائر في ارواح الشباب
الايرانيين الذين يحتجون على سياسات هذا
الدكتور حسن هلا امر كذلك في اوروبا من
انهم هناك من يرى بضروره دعم الشعب
الايراني اكثر مما يقدم الغرب له الان في
هذه الاحتجاجات والاخر يقول بان ربما هذا
الدعم قد يضر همم الثوره الايرانيه او
الاحتجاجات في ايران
يعني رسمي همم الدول الاوروبيه متعلقه ما
زالت الى حد الساعه يعني تتمنى ان يتم
انقاذ الاتفاق النووي سواء ربما لاسباب
اقتصاديه لانهم يعلمون جيدا بان ايران سوق
مهمه ولكن لا يرضى ما يكلك لان هناك نفط
وغاز ايراني لكن ايران الى هذه الدراجه
عفوا الدول الاوروبيه ما زالت متسبتها
بالاتفاق النووي لكن الاصوات هنا تقول في
النهايه ان العوده الى هذا الاتفاق هو في
النهايه الضربه كبيره للشاعر على الايراني
وانه من صحيح همم عدم استقبال ما في بعض
رموز المعارضه همم لان هذا في النهايه يتم
تسويقه ايرانيا رسميا بان المعارض الذي
لها اجنده اجنبيه لكن على الاقل عدم
العوده وعدم التسرع في العوده الى الاتفاق
لان هذا الاتفاق في النهايه اتفاق النووي
سينقض النظام الايراني وسيكون هذا يعني
اربع يوجه ضربه قاضيه للشارع الايراني
في قضيه النظام يعني يعني نحن الان امام
يعني معذره ام ازمه يعني النظام القطبيه
الثنائيه الموروث الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اثبت اثبت محدودينته لكن لدينا هنا وخاصه
نحن في اوروبا يعني
همم نتمسك بقضيه الدبلوماسيه المتعدده
الاطراف يعني ان الامم المتحده هي في
النهايه احسن ترجمه لانه بماسيه متعدده
اطراف يعني تترك للجميع الحق في المشاركه
في صراع القرار لكن ان تكون دوله عضو في
مجلس الامن اي ان هي اصلا مسؤوله على حفظ
الامن والسلم الجماعي حسب نفاق الامم
المتحده هي اصلا معنيه بهذه الحرب التي
تستعمل حق الفيتو ففعل نحن الان امام ازمه
كبيره وهي لا لا الامم المتحده ونظام
السلم الجماعي استطاع فعلا ان يجد مقاربه
مهمه لهذا الصراع ولا القطبيه اثناء
ثنائيه ان تصمد امام دول اخرى بدات تاتي
مثل الصين الهند دول اخرى كما كذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تريد كذلك ان تشارك في صناعه الاقرار ولا
تريد ان تتلقى هذا القرار هل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ستعقبل في النهائي
بمشاركه بمشاركه هذه الدول بان يكون هناك
النظام اكثر افقيه وليس نظام عمودي اعتقد
انه من الصعب الان التنبه
بارهاسات او بشكل النظام الجديد لكن
النظام القديم انا اعتقد انه اثبت فعلا
فشله هو اثبت محدوديته هناك كذلك غياب
كبير للزعماء يعني انا فقط في اوروبا هناك
تخبط كبير في صناعه ركن الاجتماعات
الاتحاد الاوروبي اصبحت اجتماعات تختلف عن
الاجتماعات التي رايناها التي حضرت جزء
منها يعني مثلا لان هناك يعني بحث على
الزعيم الاوروبي الرئيس مكرونه الذي اراد
ان يكون هو ياخذ محل همم المستشار امريكا
لم يستطيع كذلك الذي اراد ان يقول بانه
اوروبا ليست قوه اقتصاديه وانما كذلك هي
قادره سياسيه لم يستطيع كذلك هذا بالاضافه
الى القضايا الداخليه التي تغلق لحد
الاوروبي التجعل منه في النهايه يعني
تابعا له قرار اخري قرار ثاني ياخذ في
واشنطن وبت- لا يؤدي الى عمليه التعدديه
في صراع القرار الدوليه الدكتور عبد
المنعم عود اليك من جديد ما تفضل به
الدكتور حسنين هل توافق علي من انه من
الصعوبه كما قلت سابقا القراءه همم شكل
النظام العالمي الجديد ولكن ايضا هل من
الممكن ان تتخلل الولايات المتحده عن
دورها لاي قوه قادمه ام ستحدث مواجهه على
الاقل حتى لا يت- لا تتغير موازين القوه
في العالم
يعني كلمه القطبيه تعني قدره الدوله من
الدول على الوصول الى جميع الكوكب الذي
دكتور يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال بالدكتور عبد
المنعم سنعود اليه طيب دكتور سعد اذا كان
اذا كنت سامع سؤال ولا اعيده لا تحب
الاعاده
هل تتخلل الولايات المتحده عن دورها في
قياده هذا العالم وبالتالي نذهب الى قياده
بشكل مشترك او على الاقل تتنازل عن جزء من
من
ما تعتبره حقوقها لدول اخرى ليتشكل نظام
عالم جديد على الاقل
لا شوف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه دوله
هائله يعني هائله هائله الحجم وهائله
الاقتصاد وهائله القوه العسكريه والتاثير
العالمي ال ال الدخل القومي الامريكي
يعادل حوالي ربع دخل العالم يعني اقتصاد
الامريكي يعادل ربع الاقتصاد العالمي
وبالتالي هي سيكون لديها اذرع في كل مكان
لكن هناك ما يسمى بتركيز الاهتمامات في
هذه الفتره انا اعتقد بان لديها اهتمام في
موضوع اوروبا في اوكرانيا وموضوع ثاني
والصين بدرجه الاولى طبعا هو ينسحب هذا
الكلام على علاقتها بكوريا جنوبيه وكوريا
الشماليه طيب هذا لا يعني ستخلل بقيه
العالم لان لها مصالح اخطبوطيه مشتركه في
كل الاجزاء العالم ومن ثم هي المساله تصبح
مساله طيب
اولويات نعم تحديد امريكا الان شرق اسيا
واوكرانيا او روسيا تحديدا ومحاوله اغراء
بوتين في هذا المستنق الاوكراني انا اعتقد
يعني طبعا في هذا الملف بالذات دعني اقول
ان قراءه متواضعه في العام 2023 ستكون
كالاتي الاوروبيون لن يتحملوا استمرار هذا
الوضع على ما هو عليه هذا التوتر وهذا
التراجع الاقتصادي وهذا حتى حزمه
المساعدات التي قدمتها بعض هذه الدول هي
منهجه الاقتصاداتها لا تستطيع ان ان تحافظ
عليها دوما يعني وصعود هذا اليمين مثل ما
تفضل دكتور حسن سواء في الاخوه همم في
ايطاليا اسمهم الاخوه اول ماسينال اللي هو
الجبهه الوطنيه في فرنسا ربما من السلطه
والاسبان والمجر والمجريون يتحدثون طيب
وما يمينيه معه بوتن وضد حتى اوكرانيا
ويوقفون المساعدات
من اوكرانيا وغيرها طيب انا اعتقد انه
قادم 2023 الاوروبيين غير حسن ما لم
يبيعوا ان يخفف هو الضغط الامريكي عليهم
باكراهم مع رؤوس واضح واضحه هذه النقطه
اعود الى الدكتور عبد المنعم سعيد دكتور
عبد المنعم اهلا بك مجددا يعني عذرنا هذا
هذه التقنيه
يعني الاتصالات لكن كنت تقول بان القطبيه
هي استطاعه الدوله او هذا القطب الوصول
الى العالم
بالضبط ولا يوجد في هذا الحق يعني الا
دولتين في العالم ما هي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين كلاهما يصل تقريبا الى
جميع انحاء العالم بعلاقات تجاريه
واتصاليه وجاسوسيه وفضائيه كل ما تستطيع
ان ان تقوله فاحنا الذي كان لدينا الحرب
البارده نظام القطبيه لوحدها صعود الصيني
تم بتوافق مع الولايات المتحده موضوع وليس
سياسي بمعنى ان الصين باتت هي السوق
الرئيسيه للاستثمارات الامريكيه خارج
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والعكس ايضا
صحيح وهي ان السوق الامريكيه هي السوق
الكبير بالنسبه للصين عندما تحدث مجموعه
ازمات واا يعاني العالم في التعامل مع مثل
الكرونه ومثل الحرب الاوكرانيه تكون هذه
لحظه مراجعه للنظام الموجود وماذا فعليته
وانا ارى ان من نشاهده الان لانه الب لم
يقوم مثلا باي شيء تجاه هذه الحرب بالعكس
ان احد اعضائه الهامين وهو روسيا لم تلقى
تايدا مباشره من بقيه اعضاء البريكس همم
اوروبا رغم التحول نحو اليمين ووجود قلق
من الانفاق على الحرب الاوكرانيه الا ان
تصريحات واضحه اليوم في ايطاليا التي هي
الاكثر تطرفا نحو اليمين تقول ان منح
اثنين وثلاثه من 10 مليار او مليارات اخرى
من قبل اوروبا سواء من بريطانيا او من
ايطاليا او من غيرها الى اوكرانيا هو
الطريقه الوحيده اللي وقف الحرب يعني
شايفين انه عندما تصمت اوكرانيا فان روسيا
سوف تكون اكثر قابليه للتسويه مما اذا
كانت منتصره همم وفائزه همم السياسه
اليوميه الاوروبيه شيء طبيعي في بلاد يعني
ديمقراطيه والاعلام يلعب دورا مهما فيها
لكن التصريحات انا اعتقد انها الان
اكثر في اتجاه القبول
بدول جديده الى داخل الحلف الاطلسي وانه
الاتجاه هو حاولت كسب الحرب وايضا هزم
تحاوله روسيا دكتور عبد المنعم سعيد عضو
مجلس الشيوخ شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور ايضا
حسن عبيد والساده العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
جنيف والمحاضر في معهد العلوم السياسيه في
باريس شكرا جزيلا لك ومن الكويت الدكتور
سعد بن طفله العجمي وزير الاعلام السابق
والكاتب الصحفي والاستاد الجامعي شكرا
جزيلا لكم كل عام وانتم بخير ايضا نتمنى
لكم عاما سعيدا جديدا ان شاء الله